retour en france plusieurs milliers
d'enfants et leurs familles se sont
réunis aujourd'hui à paris au palais
omnisports de bercy autour du cardinal
lustiger pour un dimanche de fête de
rencontres de découvertes et de prière
pour l'archevêque de paris dont le
charisme et la popularité ont trouvé là
une nouvelle illustration
ce fut l'occasion d'affirmer
l'importance de la froid pour les jeunes
et d'insister sur le rôle essentiel des
familles auprès de jacques garnier le
cardinal jean marie lustiger a de quoi
être satisfait sa journée de fête de
rencontres et de découvertes avec les
enfants parisien a dépassé ses
espérances
ils ont été près de dix mille
aujourd'hui à bercy à ce rapprochement
avec l'église qui met en eux son
espérance pour construire une
civilisation basée sur l'amour la
famille aux yeux de l'archevêque de
paris a un rôle primordial en
s'adressant aux parents il leur a
rappelé leur responsabilité essentielle
car si chaque enfant a droit à la vie il
a droit à leur amour et c'est un don
qu'il aurait été confié ils doivent en
être responsable
on possède pas l'enfant que l'on passait
dans leur appartenant comme on possède
une voiture reçoit un enfant j'allais
dire comme un cadeau que dieu donne et
on les reçoit pour l'enlever pour lui
donner le meilleur de nous mêmes quand
les enfants ne savent pas aimer pour
eux-mêmes et aimer comme existants
vraiment vous allez tout ce qui se passe
actuellement dans la civilisation des
goisses qui fiche quand la drogue il
reste alors qu'est ce qui peut les aider
moi je pense sur un second concerne et
en ce qui concerne tous les croyants
c'est de transmettre comme une priorité
la chance de la vie c'est à dire la
connaissance de dieu et la connaissance
de la raison paul kagame sur cette terre
la connaissance du bien et du mal et ça
nous transmettre un passé moi je trouve
triste je trouve dramatique dramatique
pour une civilisation qu'on préfère un
bogie progresse que de catéchisme ça pas
de sens